up to 30 000 people gathered in the
northern city of banuluka to show
support for long-time nationalist leader
milorad dodic
it's not for Sarajevo to determine who
our president will be the people have
had their say in the elections dodic is
the president they can keep counting the
votes for another hundred years if they
wish we know the truth
dodic is claiming victory in the recent
election for President of the province
of Republica serbska the autonomous Serb
Republic in Bosnia Herzegovina but
election officials say they're concerned
about irregularities and vote rigging an
investigation is underway dodic
supporters reject allegations of
electoral fraud
I came here to show support for
president who was elected in an honest
way we don't want the central Election
Commission to manage our destination
during the rally doddick again talked
about separating from Bosnia Herzegovina
we will leave for sure and we will take
49 of territory of Bosnia and
Herzegovina with us I deeply believe in
an independent republic of serbska it's
impossible to build coexistence in
Bosnia with people who want to prevent
your freedom
dodic's rival Jelena trivich says she
won the election the Electoral
commission has ordered all the ballots
be sent to the capital Sarajevo where
they're now being recounted Victoria
Gayton B Al Jazeera